احنا بنستنكر اللي بصير بالسودان يعني شعب
الله يكون بعونه الشعب مسكين وطيب الله
يكون بعونهم يعني اللي بصير فيهم هذا
والله يا حرام يعني الدنيا داخله على عيد
والله يكون بعونهم يا رب بصراحه اللي
بيحدث حاليا في السودان اكيد ما في حدا
عربي او مسلم بيرضى في هيك وضع بصير احنا
الشعب السوداني شعب شقيق شعب عربي مسلم ما
في حدا منا اكيد بيرضى اللي بصير فيه احنا
بنستنكر الفسير في السودان عشان السودان
اخوتنا واحنا كنا بلد واحد بلد عربي
شيء مؤسف اللي عم يصير بالسودان بس يعني
بالمجمل نحن اكيد مع كل شيء اسمه شرعيه
ومع الجيش ودود اي انقلاب اي دوله عربيه
حرام اي دوله عربيه يصير فيها انقلاب امني
اول شيء الشعب السودان شعب معطر الحرام
اللي عم يصير فيها هيك السودان بلا بلد
شقيق بلد عربي واللي بيحصل ده طبعا صعب
جدا وفي مشكله بوجه كلمه للشعب السوداني
ان هم يصمدوا ويكونوا ايد واحده مع بعضيهم
لان اللي بيحصل دون بيفرج العالم كله
عليهم التكالب على السلطه وفرض الراي مش
هيوصل السودان الا في الحديد وبلاش موضوع
الانقلابات والحاجات اللي دي لان دي عماله
تضيع في وقت كبير جدا وبتستهلك ثروات
السودان واقتصاد السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات